on tonight's NFL Network air at 8:00
Eastern Time is some must-see television
Brian Dawkins a football life Brian
Dawkins here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Pro Football Hall of Famer Brian
Dawkins
I'm doing fine have you seen the piece
yet have you seen the hour I have not
seen it so as everybody else sees it
okay you will be seeing it as well I
mean what what is your recollections of
the Hall of Fame weekend been now just a
couple of months removed from it Brian
your speech was quite something else to
say the least yeah it was from my heart
100% from my heart and just the
beginning of things that are going to
happen going forward I've already
started some of the things that I'm
doing I've been doing them I better man
better land challenges and what better
land conference I'm so like to be able
to have that experience to go down to
the Hall of Fame just see all those the
legends and and to experience that and
have experience that I've had with what
the Eagles fans with the Broncos fans
and to really be able to allow them to
see inside of me
and that's what I try to do on stage I
try to be as transparent as possible to
be able to bless people to help people
go on through some of the things that
they may be going through so that's you
know in a quick synopsis that's kind of
what that Hall of Fame was for me and do
you think are you prepared or do you
know if tonight's a football life is
going to include part of your internal
mental struggles at all Brian it will
because that's something that I made
sure that we talked about because I
think it's extremely important to have
those conversations to let to let people
know that you know this is not they're
not the only ones going through what
they're going through and you know that
it's and like I said in my speech there
is hope on the other side there's hope
there's hoping and you know to get
caught up where you are to remain where
you are but I would have never been able
to see the man that I am today had I got
caught up and stayed where I was in
those times of displeasure and pain know
when I was interviewing you and in those
years of consecutive Pro Bowls and
obviously McNabb on offense and read and
all those years where you were can
tenders for the Super Bowl made it one
year you were struggling with happiness
at that time not necessarily so that's
the thing about it's not a continuous
Trek it's not a always thing um it's
something that can creep up and come and
go and that's one thing that I'm saying
we throw terms around too loosely no
depression and and the like I think you
know sometimes it's just me going
through some some turbulence in your
life sometimes it's just a whole bunch
of stuff at the same time and you
haven't you know some adverse reactions
as far as emotions are concerned I think
we just throw the terms around too
loosely so that when someone is actually
going through something that is it's
very substantial I think that it gets
kind of lost into everything so you know
going through some of the things that I
went through in the beginning of my
career it's what I really tried to focus
on in my speech because that is where a
lot of pressure was upon me so but a lot
of things I didn't have the answers I
didn't have the mental aptitude I didn't
have the spiritual aptitude to be able
to deal with the things about that that
was coming towards me so there's a lot
of negativity there's a lot of things
that were happening chemical reactions
in my head that was actually actually
happened as well that brought a lot of
negativity to my mind a lot of thoughts
to my mind a lot of a lot of things to
my mind that that caused those things
those thoughts to come up those
suggestions even for myself to do
specific things to myself like I said
people were suicide so like that's kind
of continuous day that's not every
moment of the day type of thing
I wanted to make sure I focus on that
part of my life but I also know that
going forward in my life that that is
something that is always there it's
always in the back corner just waiting
for an opportunity to give me those
negative thoughts so that's why for me I
do specific things in my life I'm a
disciplined individual I do specific
things in my life now that helped fall
off in a ward off a lot of those things
that would try to even creep back into
my thoughts football life with Brian
Dawkins tonight on NFL Network at 8:00
Eastern Time could not be a more
deserving
recipient of a football life as well as
a Pro Football Hall of Fame acceptance
and enshrinement Brian Dawkins here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you think of
the Eagles last night Brian what'd you
think of that one yeah they got back to
playing the ball playing a game like
they're supposed to play it with a chip
you know I'm playing with an edge and
you saw that offensively and defensively
obviously there's always going to be
something that you need to fix and they
stopped hurting themselves I think in
the last in their losses they had a
whole bunch of self-inflicted wounds so
to speak a lot of all sides a lot of
holding penalties put themselves behind
the sticks on offense didn't all stand
on the field defensively with the pass
interference call or something like that
giving up big place so those are the
type of things that they were hurting
themselves with a little bit in those
games and I think last night you really
saw them hopefully put a lot of those
things to bed and hopefully they'll
begin to support the system you know I
think where do you think they get that
that grit from do you think it's wence
being able to play the way that he is
the play calling from the coach the
mindset from from who where do you think
the grit can comes from in Philadelphia
well the grit obviously you know your
quarterback having him back at the hell
you know is there's a huge plus
obviously because you know at one point
he was the MVP of the National Football
League lies just be honest with it and
so we have him back in the helm doing
what he does the way he's able to do it
that you know excites the sideline of
your defensive player watching him on
the football - you're doing it the way
that he does it escaping and running it
up still liked him to get that I slide
clicker and stop taking those hits but
that's another conversation but I I
personally loved the fact that they lost
early and I honestly love the fact that
they lost a couple of games in a row
because that really it really lets you
know what you have it really lets you
know what you need to work on now you
really can have tough conversations you
really can call catch to the carpet and
really talk about some stuff and then
you see the type of team you have is it
a lot of finger-pointing and if it is
you need to take care of it and leaders
need to dance step up to half the
conversations they need to have it's not
about calling people out sometimes about
sometimes pulling somebody to the side
and let them know hey this is how we're
gonna have to fix what we're doing
what you're doing is not helping so I
like the fact that they lost I don't
know one crazy I don't know this but
coming off of a Super Bowl did not know
one was what it feels like to have to
try to defend I like the fact that they
lost early games that didn't get blown
out there for the most part it's things
that they could have done to actually
win those games they actually lost a
couple of games I believe they should
have won but at the same time once again
now you really can whole cats you know
to a higher standard because your music
and now you can talk about difficult
things that you probably couldn't talk
about when you lose well there's a lot
of difficult things that need to be
talked about in New York now after what
the Eagles did last night certainly with
Eli Manning somebody who was playing in
the secondary in Philadelphia when Eli
first arrived in New York and you
watched him ascend to his first Super
Bowl victory season in oh seven you
played him twice a year now seeing him
at the very end do you think he is at
the end do you think it's over for Eli
Brian Dawkins I don't think it's like
over like let's just close the cast no
no dude I think if you look at and you
look at when Leal I had a success and
documented he had protection he was able
to seven to his throws and when he does
not he can't step it to his throat so he
doesn't feel that comfort his eyes do
have kin to come down and he begins to
bail out of the back of the pocket or
throw off his back foot or leaning back
away from his throws because he doesn't
trust the protection in front of them
and so that's you know that's been on
the giant that they have not shoot that
up that offensive line up for lorna you
haven't know of communities gonna be
all-pro back real soon in the backfield
you know being able to run the ball and
catch the ball out of the backfield so
they have a tremendous weapon there but
until they show that lineup that have
give Eli the chance to step it to blows
and it really feel comfortable in the
pocket then you won't see you won't see
the guy that that you know that that I
know Stu balls but he got into some arms
are some comfort in those runs that he
was beginning to you know to move the
office to move the ball and you can see
a lot of that had to do with attachment
until they protect that do
it's gonna look just as good then I got
about 90 seconds left here for guy who
used to put on that breathe right and
transform himself you called yourself
the idiot man when you put that breathe
right on in Philadelphia what advice
would you give to Odell about playing
under control well you have to channel
in the right way I love the energy I
love all these things I'm gonna do I
love the fact the fact that he has you
have to challenge the right way and
can't be in such a way that you're
holding the ballclub
when you start having having the media
going to your teammate actually asking
them about what you're doing
you're becoming a distraction to the
team so as much as you love the game I
said what does I love in fact if you
have these emotions for you have to
learn to channel it in the right way to
utilize it in the right way and not have
it that you now have the coast after
that has a question me I have the answer
question now Bartley
I mean they're going to be continuously
asking questions about what they think
about Odile and what he's doing now it
should not be the case use that energy
that you have in the right way
international business at the team hey
Brian it was awesome having a front-row
seat for your enshrinement after having
watch you played and become the man that
you are and be the man that you are
first member of Clemson football in the
Pro Football Hall of Fame representing
the Eagles and now tonight on a football
life I can't wait to see it Congrats on
everything going on with you believe
this young young small looking safety
from Jacksonville Florida has the chance
to now have see himself in a football
life I thought that that was four four
big Thomas and you know to see myself on
that stage she's on that screen tonight
and see my family my friends get energy
talking about me it's an absolute mess
it's an absolute blast you deserve it
let's chat again soon Brian thanks to
the club you got it that's a Brian
Dawkins football life Brian Dawkins
tonight on the NFL Network the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience